μπάτετρεις φορές μέχρι τώρα ν έχε τελεύθερο χρόνο αφοείστε και πρόεδρος το δεγετικού συμβολίο το
οργανισμόύ λεμεσόςόχκαι α δεστριάπόσο υμετό κυρπια είναι εμέσω να εξασφαλισει τον τίτλο της πολιδυστικής προτεύους
α το διεστριάαυτόι δτελευθαίοα ι λεμεσώς όπως θα θυμάστε είχε δοκιμάσει το δικεπτά αλλά πετυχέ
γιατί οι οδώσει οποία την οποία πήραν τότε ι πευθυνή ήταν κάπολοδαθασμένοι εμείς διαλέξαμενάλλο δρόμο
και πρέπει να πω ότι και οι κτελεστική διευφύντρια ουείναι μαζί μας αλλά και αντιπρόεδρο
κύρίατέ βοηθούν πάρα πολύ και βλέπω επίσεις τοκαι τον παλιό αλλά και τον καινούργιο δήμαρχο
τις λεμεσού να ενιαφέλον πάρα πολύ τώρα αν θα επιτύχουμε οι όχι ένα εως το
ξέρι γιατί εκτός από τες πολές πόλις που διαφερθήκαν διαλθεί καν εγενές πολύς υτές που
έχουν γίνει πρόσφαταπτο κούριον μαζίπδο ιψωνακαλι πριν τις λευκωσίες και τις άρανακας δεν είναι ένα
εύκολογηχείρημα καθόλου αλλά αν πετύχουμε να πάρουν δο τίλο και θα φέλει η εργασία άλλων
πέδε χρόνο γιατί ότιτλος μπορεί να αποδοθία τοπέε αλλά θα πρέπει μέχρι τοτριάδ α έγινουν
πάραπρόλα πράγματα και μετά ακόμη τρια τεσερα χρόνια θα πρέπει κανείς να εξοδεψει και λεες